ja ich habe mich sehr gefreut diese
woche dass die das familienministerium
ministerium für frauen familie und
integration heißt das genau von
katharina binz in rheinland pfalz einen
kleinen wettbewerb ausgeschrieben hat
ich muss ich gucke ungern auf zettel
aber ich muss es ablesen damit ich
niemanden aus dass sie die initiative
richtet sich an alle lesbischen schwulen
bisexuellen transienten hinter
geschlechtlichen und nicht die
lehrerinnen nicht binären winzerinnen
und winzer aus rheinland pfalz und die
können jetzt noch bis zum ende februar
ihren wein einreichen und als queer wein
werden wieder bewertet einen abnehmer
gibt es auch schon das ministerium mit
500 flaschen kaufen dürfen nicht mehr
als zehn euro kosten und dann hinterher
als repräsentations geschenke und das
volk bringen das feine sache ich weiß
nicht genau was die traube wie die sich
beim keltern anders verhält wenn es
unterschiedliche sexuelle orientierung
gibt ich weiß noch nicht was der
weinkenner davon hat wenn der winzer
irgendeiner anderen neigung dazu gehört
als er selbst keine ahnung im klartext
es ist ein wettbewerb für winzer die
sich auch jetzt schon an allen
wettbewerben beteiligen können aber
einen speziellen wettbewerb bekommen für
ihre sexuelle orientierung
außer heteros die dürfen natürlich nicht
machen das ist klar was will man damit
erreichen was was soll das es ist so ein
bisschen hereinspaziert hereinspaziert
jahrmarkt der identitäten
jetzt stellen wir einfach mal leute die
deren handwerk nichts mit ihrer
sexuellen identität zu tun hat den
bieten wir auch mal eine bühne was soll
das ich kann es mir nicht erklären
es hat sich übrigens noch keiner
gemeldet das ist gehört mit dazu hälfte
der ausschreibungs hat sich noch keiner
gemeldet aber voller erfolg ehrlich
gesagt weiß man kann darauf regnen kann
ich denke mir ist doch nett das ist ja
deren eigener wettbewerb das stört mich
jetzt gar nicht so sehr es ist
aber naja ich habe immer so ein bisschen
den verdacht dass hinter dieser woche
bewegung schon auch beinhart aktivisten
stehen und wenn man da mal genauer in
die papiere reim ließen in die webseiten
dann merkt man schon dass da die
überwindung des hetero normativen
weltbild ist dahinter steht und da sage
ich mir einfach leute
nirgends auf der welt kann man so frei
alles ausleben was man so in sich hat
wie hier solange es keine anderen
betrifft aber
warum will man das mehrheits konstrukt
der klassischen familie jetzt in ein
licht stellen als sei es nur eines unter
vielen was was soll dass diese
gesellschaft lebt von den familien dann
steht im grundgesetz besonderer schutz
von ehe und familie die leisten bei der
kindererziehung am anfang des lebens
brachial
gute leistungen die man nicht staatlich
ersetzen kann sie leisten am ende des
lebens enorm viel bei der pflege und
daneben gibt es tausende spielarten von
wegen zum glück die alle akzeptiert sind
bei uns was soll solche demonstrativen
aktionen als wäre da irgend etwas
aufzuholen also ich würden trinken
bier schmeckt ist doch gut also ich
finde es gar nicht schlimm ich glaube
auch nicht dass die familien in
deutschland zugrunde gehen wenn winzer
in rheinland-pfalz dafür ausgezeichnet
werden das den guten wein machen ich
finde die sexuelle identität sollte bei
der weinherstellung auch keine rolle
spielen aber vielleicht probieren sie
ihn auch mal der weiß was es bei ihnen
auslöst dann find kein so ein
weintrinker ich würde jemand wir bier
trinken
ich finde
es ist nicht so schlecht was ist wenn
ich meine die wir haben deutlich
sträflich vernachlässigt tischler gibt
es zu wenige davon aber ich finde jetzt
wird nicht klar ist also der vorschlag
von vorwagen die möchte sollte jetzt
umso mehr wenn frau wagenknecht so eine
art mitherausgeber schaffen
das heißt ja dann würde eingeschränkt
auf bestimmte änderungen also ich würde
es machen
ich habe ja die kohle wird's machen wir
können das auch hier zusammen ich
fürchte ich möchte wusste dass man dass
man der land einen bärendienst erweist
indem man sich ins schaufenster stellt
anstatt sie einfach als normale menschen
zu behandeln die sich an wettbewerben
beteiligen ja ich meine im grunde war ja
und das ist ja wirklich eine
errungenschaft der kampf über viele
viele jahrzehnte war ja einfach dass es
keine rolle mehr spielt ob jemand
heterosexuelle homosexuell oder was auch
immer ist und ich finde eigentlich also
wenn man es jetzt mal ernsthaft noch mal
betrachtet das ist ja das ziel das
musste erreicht werden und das ist
großartig
und ich meine da passt so was nicht dazu
dass es dann plötzlich mit umgekehrten
vorzeichen wieder eine ganz besondere
rolle spielt und ich glaube auch als
schade tatsächlich weil es leute er ja
ich meine wir haben ja mehr drüber
gelacht das ist eigentlich auch eher
lustig aber manche leute wenn sie zu oft
erleben dass sie dann doch irgendwie er
wieder vorbehalte entwickeln und das ist
nicht sinnvoll als großer anhänger von
markt und wettbewerb finde ich der
wettbewerber zu richten und dass ich
noch keiner beteiligten hatte sagt es
möglicherweise auch aus über die
sinnhaftigkeit nicht ganzen unternehmens
aus